[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
le premier de l'année 2018 fait donc une
excellente nouvelle année avec un
sommaire très complet et des paveurs
très compétente comme jean baptiste
duclair bonjour bonjour patrice
enseignant à l'université de versailles
saint quentin et pêcheur devant
l'éternel
c'est une passion c'est une passion qui
me prend je n'oserais dire presque
autant le droit que le droit puisque je
devrais je passe beaucoup de temps la
nuit auprès des dames sont de la
mécanique qui arrive à beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs au barreau de versailles
on va parler avec vous dès hier de
recours du barreau de versailles contre
une mesure qui avait été autorisé par
l'ancien ministre de la justice monsieur
revoit ses qui consiste à mettre balle
et les gens qui sont jugés dans des
cartes de verre du mans stéphane mans
sont vos projets opérés il a cité de
versailles saint quentin
bonne année bonne année moi je mange les
produits de pêche quand même et je vais
envoyer les cages et dégustation de
patron on peut le dire n'y reviendrai
les gens savent déjà dix jours éditeurs
avec un bal le premier opus de mélissa
faisait un peu les passagers perdus
c'est ce qu'on appelle un de stéphane
bella j'aime pas le terme mais c'est un
feel good book démarquer roman
autorisant mais pas que c'était la
goutte
oui j'écoute beaux essais
cela dit alors on peut parler du livre
si on veut régler mais c'est vrai que on
est dans une époque où on a envie que ça
eh bien non je pense qu'elle est par
exemple regarder des les émissions de
débats pour nager tous aller j'en ai un
peu marre j'ai l'impression par exemple
et on a envie plutôt de choses plus
positives souvient-il
nous on ne semblait enfin en tant que le
créditeur puisque là donc c'est un
bouquin assez autorisant mais même
chante sur les polars classiques et pour
l'instant je m'applique à une préférence
pour les les rendements sont pas trop
glauque peut y avoir des peut y avoir
des crimes
il y aura des enquêtes mais y avoir des
tonnes de choses mais mes de la
surenchère d'hémoglobine d'éventration
et d'éviscération se calme un peu
c'est peut-être pas plus mal à l'aise
les gens du dessous un peu apaisées et
il ya des noms nantel qui montre alors
ce pas très nouveau mais enfin que le
cinéma sur les comédies qui sont
plébiscités par les par les spectateurs
il ya le livre de pierre lemaitre
qui avait eu beaucoup avec revoir à la
hausse ses vraies couleurs de l'
incendie est un livre plus gai par
exemple que celui qui fait d'habitude je
sais pas je crois que vous l'avez lu
c'est le nom à ses envies de saint roman
formidable humour ya du bruit tout
essayé du mieux même s'il ya des
tensions quand même assez forte dans le
libre c'est vrai que ça fait ça fait du
bien ça qui fait du bien quand on lit ça
détend ça on part dans un autre univers
et remonte le temps ce très très bien
c'est un très beau livre tendance là
stéphane est ce que vous pensez de 2018
c'est une année à vouloir se faire du
bien non pas spécialement
je pensais toujours eu l'impression
qu'il fallait se faire du bien afin
qu'il fallait avant de refaire le
bonheur etc mais que je j'allais
j'allais ajouter à votre propos
pardonnez-moi mais surtout en ce moment
voyez ici on en entends tu en entends
souvent voire toujours dire oui on a
besoin de se détendre
on a besoin de ré surtout en ce moment
mais c'est tout le temps en réalité
ah oui juste qu'on entend
sachant ce que je vois mais je ne sais
pas alors y at il une saison pour le
feel good book ou le fil bakbou coup
feelgood film se passe et saison en tout
cas il ya une mode indéniable après
c'est une pluie mais la menace et les
modes donc ça ça durera probablement pas
mais et mais c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
c'est à la mode les gens on achète ça on
a envie de ça donc
mais regardez tous les to les toutes les
comédies par exemple de cinéma qui
auront marché c'est des choses qui
s'ouvre sur qu'est ce qu'on a fait au
bon dieu enfin tu aideras tous et tous
ces films qui ont fait des grands succès
qui ouvre un peu l'esprit c'est à dire
que c'est des gens qui sont un peu les
esprits fermé au départ et qui soit un
peu que ce soit sur le handicap soit non
pas ce jeu non on peut aussi se faire du
mal combine une mauvaise comédie soeur
du bien parce que c'est épuisant
en tout cas mais quel que soit le les
intrigues où les scénarios à poil
d'humour ne peut faire des films très
noire des livres très loi avec un peu
d'humour et ça s'est toujours dit comme
disait je ne sais quel philosophe c'est
bon de rire parfois c'est plutôt à c'est
plutôt ça fait du bien de voir que les
gens ont plus envie de parler des trains
qui arrivent à l'heure que des trains
qui arrivent en retard parce qu'on est
plutôt un peuple réputé pour être
grognon mais on a changé le pc c'est
vrai et c'est plutôt que c'est plutôt
rations à de croire un peu on nous
oublie pas triste
vous souhaite d'avoir une petite lueur
au bout du tunnel nous sommes un grand
peuple de ma vie sans corde et les
espoirs pouvoir raccroche à ce petit
bout de terre qui nous maintient encore
doux et bien de l'humour
enfin dans son procès ben y en avait
mais il veut conjointe du département
des yvelines et des départements des
hauts-de-seine propose de regarder un
petit sujet alors c'est à dire que il ya
une volonté de regrouper ces deux
départements est ce que c'est possible
est-ce que ça se heurte à une volonté
politique qui est celle du président de
la république de faire le grand paris on
regarde le fais et on en parle tout de
suite après panneau lumineux géant pin's
pétition à l'entrée le ton est donné les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine refuse la
future métropole et l'ont fait savoir ce
mardi soir lors de leur cérémonie de
voeux commune
ce redécoupage étudié par l'état vise à
créer une métropole de rang mondial
limité à paris à la petite couronne exit
les autres départements de la région
parisienne dont les yvelines
on nous parle de simplification mais
c'est pour inventer un chaque fois de
nouvelles usines à gaz qui nous
contraignent à des dépenses d'énergie et
d'argent considérables sans jamais
produire le moindre bénéfice mesurable
il mesure qui mettra en péril la fusion
entre les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
un rapprochement opéré depuis 2016 vous
avez une voiture qui est en panne et une
voiture qui marche
vous prenez pas la voiture qui marche
pour réparer la voiture qui est en panne
c'est ce qui est en train de faire le
gouvernement et ça ça m'agace parce que
c'est dramatique
ça nous mettra tous à pied là où il
faudrait qu'on monte dans une voiture
qui est celle de la croissance dans leur
sillage les présidents des cinq autres
départements d'île de france ont pris la
parole au pupitre ou via des vidéos pour
dénoncer ce futur redécoupage le
socialiste le communiste l'homme de
droite
tous ces gens sont ensemble sont
d'accord il faut décentraliser parce que
un service public qui fonctionne c'est
un service qui est à proximité des
besoins des usagers pour la république
en marche le scénario n'est pas encore
tranchée l'elysée devrait communiquer
dans les prochaines semaines sur le
nouveau statut de cette métropole
tout dépend des compétences qui seront
affectés aussi aux différentes entités
je pense en tout cas ce qui est attendu
c'est plus d'efficacité et plus de
simplicité parce qu'aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens ils savent pas forcément
qu'elle est l'entité pertinente pour
quelles actions à mener pour apaiser les
tensions la soirée s'est clôturée par
des concerts de musique classique la
chanson devrait être différent dans les
prochains jours sur la scène politique
régionale le 31 janvier les sept
présidents de départements se
rassembleront de nouveau à boulogne
billancourt pour défendre une métropole
régionale
voilà c'était à la nouvelle salle
musicale de boulogne alors évidemment
c'est sérieux c'est pas tout à fait
nouveau parce que la volonté de
rapprochement de ces deux départements
qui sont probablement deux des
départements les plus riches de france
elle est assez ancien alors on peut
faire un juste juridiquement c'est
possible de regrouper des départements
oui oui la loi de 2015 qui a
qui est l'un des éléments de la grande
réforme territoriale de 2014 2015 qui a
notamment abouti à la fusion de
plusieurs régions la loi de 2015
comporte une disposition selon laquelle
conformément à une procédure
particulière il sera désormais possible
au département de fusionner mais il faut
savoir tout de même que l'état a
toujours son mot à dire décentralisation
cela n'équivaut pas système fédéral ou
que sais-je encore
les collectivités territoriales sont des
entités administratives qui veut dire
des entités soumises à la volonté
globale de la loi et le moins c'est
l'état donc l'état a toujours une forme
d'autorité à faire valoir et c'est
plutôt me semble-t-il très bien sur ces
questions là donc les départements ne
sont pas libres évidemment de s'auto
institué ou de se dissoudre comme on
pourrait parfois le croire à entendre
les discours portait par certains par
certains élus locaux
donc il ya en effet une volonté c'est
toujours presque là encore une fois une
forme d'alibi une volonté de
simplification de réduire les strates de
ce fameux millefeuille territorial que
alive mille feuilles
là il ya un vrai millefeuille c'est vrai
entre paris et la région
si vous avez trop derrière et c'est pas
ce n'est pas un reproche c'est au fond
tout à fait enfin entre guillemets
naturel il ya toujours des coups
politiques attachés rire derrière les
discours portait parlée par les élus y
compris les élus locaux ici s'agit de
grands élus locaux il ya des questions
de rivalité entre la région ile de
france les départements de la petite et
la grande couronne
l'existence de la métropole du grand
paris dont on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
trop à quoi ça sert à quoi elle sert
écoutez coûtait trop cher la cour des
comptes
l'a signalé il ya une dizaine de jours
donc voilà le paysage est d'une telle
complexité que il est quand même très il
est difficile même de saisir l'objectif
de tout cela il ya pas de il semble
quand même assez on veut résumer un peu
les choses qu'ils aient un lien projet
d'emmanuel bacrot qui serait de
regrouper paris et les départements de
la petite couronne 92 93 94
évidemment s'il ya au groupement les les
départements perdent de leur importance
la région perd de son importance
on sent bien que les dirigeants des
départements comme valérie pécresse
dirigeants de la région pour dire des
choses un peu vite à leur pré carré
bien sûr un peu ça il n'y a pas de
réforme territoriale possible sans alors
je dis l'état à sa volonté à faire
valoir sa puissance à faire la loi
on va peut-être de notre dame des landes
mais en matière de réforme territoriale
au fond politiquement rien ne se fait
sans les élus locaux eux mêmes sans leur
association qui sont très fortes
j'avais parlé ici récemment de
l'association des maires de france et
pas en cause ici des mets à
l'association des départements de france
présidée par bussereau qui constituent
des jeux d'hier des lobbys mais c'est
pas péjoratif des forces politiques
extrêmement puissante et le problème
c'est que les élus locaux sont élus
lorsqu'on est élu on a plutôt une
tendance assez logique à vouloir se
ferrer est donc hautement les élus qui
votent mais aussi exactement alors que
modern à oblige maintenant on n'y est
plus c'est pendant longtemps
jean-charles soyez un feel-good parcours
juste quelques minutes parvenait à mener
je termine mon propos si vous le voulez
bien je ne vous ai pas un terreau comme
des rayons je suis plus court
[Rires]
à situations complexes penser que les
princesses complète si vous permettez
voilà je ne sais plus ce que je dis oui
vous aviez raison de souligner que les
élus locaux à la bonne vieille période
du cumul et qu'on regrette déjà les élus
locaux votait eux mêmes les lois qui les
concernaient donc cette situation
démocratique en or dérangeait pas mais
c'était un peu le conflit d'intérêts que
qui me dérangeait tout autant dans sa
beauté des choses qui les a donc on va
bien voir c'est vrai que c'est une c'est
une sorte de de luttes de pouvoir au
fond qui se joue là qu'est ce qui sera
le plus puissant est ce que sont les
zébus est-ce que c'est l'état en fait
c'est un peu ça c'est une lutte entre
les tailles et le lait et les
départements je suis pas sûr que on
entendait patrick devedjian parler de
décentralisation jeu pas sûr que ce soit
la décentralisation qui soient au centre
du débat
je crois pas non c'est pas vraiment plus
du pouvoir enfin c'est logique toi
record c'est vrai que l'état a toujours
la mainmise sur l'organisation
territoriale de l'état
c'est une puissance régalienne donc ceci
dit la constitution interdit de
supprimer une catégorie de collectivités
territoriales donc la catégorie communes
départements régions mais on peut
ensuite supprimer des communes des
départements des régions
donc l'état normalement la toute toute
souveraineté pour modifier cela et
notamment les départements que vous avez
évoquées mais effectivement ça se heurte
à des résistances locales extrêmement
forte et chaque réforme territoriale
c'est la même histoire qu'on nous sert
c'est à dire qu'au départ on essaye de
rationner la carte territoriale rit donc
avec un dessin qui est louable avec une
manière d'organiser les choses qui a sa
cohérence et ensuite au moment de faire
passer la loi donc
au stade de la discussion il ya un
décalage b en secret entre le projet de
loi initial et le texte de loi tel qu'il
est modifiée par les membres
parlementaires qui sont eux-mêmes des
élus locaux et qui sont soumis à
certaines pressions donc on modifie un
peu ceci pour faire plaisir aux uns
modifier un peu cela pour faire plaisir
aux autres
on se retrouve finalement avec une loi
qui rend les choses beaucoup plus
complexe et beaucoup moins clair que ce
qu'elle n'était avec souvent le choix
qui est qui fait de créer un échange sur
les arts que d'augmenter boutoir tout le
monde dans une départements régions
communautés de communes communautés
urbaines communautés d'agglomération
métropole et demain que ça j'ai décidé
de départ c'est de 2,10 de supprimer à
des feuilles du millefeuille à ces ratés
enfin manifestement puisque à chaque
fois on va recréer
c'est quelque chose de plus grand se
comprend pas pourquoi on se cale pas sur
les schémas des sociétés commerciales où
il ya une société mère en dessous des
entreprises filiales et soeurs et on
pourra avoir
non c'est pas une tribune sur le schéma
donc on pourrait avoir effectivement une
grande métropole est en dessous des
départements mais au lieu d'avoir une
métropole un grand paris etc
c'est avec tout on va voir parce que
c'est vrai que rien n'a été décidé
jusqu'à présent on va peut-être en
parler sur notre dame des landes mais on
a l'impression d'avoir affaire à un
pouvoir qui aujourd'hui décide peut-être
un peu plus que ce qu'il ne se décide et
d'autres fois ci va au bout de son
projet c'est à dire demander des
départements de la petite couronne
évidemment ça va ça va 2 2 par nature
imposer une
simplification du millefeuille je pense
qu'on pourra pas garder le reste enfin
ski ski de manière plus générale se
dessine depuis une 25 ans peut-être mais
c'est vraiment à l'oeuvre dans en
matière territoriales c'est une très
forte asymétrie c'est à dire c'est pas
tant une simplification qu'une que des
schémas à la carte
le bon vieux temps où on avait
simplement les trois grandes catégories
de collectivités que jean baptiste
évoqué communes départements régions ce
bon vieux temps alors il est en
apparence toujours là mais il est dans
l'intérieur des choses et matériellement
révolte si vous avez presque du sur
mesure c'est à dire à chaque
collectivité un statut particulier alors
on a commencé par l'outre-mer ou les
collectivités d'outre-mer ont chacune
sept adultes tout à fait particulier
c'était moins le cas avant et 7 la
parcelle à rythmes oui cette grande
diversité elle elle est aujourd'hui à
l'oeuvre en métropole regardez par
exemple métropole de lyon qu est une
collectivité territoriale unique en son
genre est un appareil n'a pas d'autre
parce que c'est une collectivité une
métropole en même temps alors qu'une
métropole est en principe en
établissement public
là on pourrait avoir avec la
reconfiguration de la nouvelle île de
france aussi quelque chose sur mesure
qu'il n'existe pas encore qui c'est
assez chaud comme ça parce que peu après
nous correspond peut-être
voilà des besoins ce graphique enfin ça
ne correspond pas du tout à notre
histoire nos traditions où justement les
départements ont été créés en à 89 17
189 90 et on voulait faire à l'origine y
avait un projet pour faire déconstruire
des deux départements angle droit
n'est ce pas avec presque la
versaillaise
jardins jardin à la française parce
qu'on trouvait ça super rationnelle bon
alors ça à épouser un peu c'est pas rien
c'est la géographie des collectivités la
ville répond deux régions exactement
donc ça épouse un peu le milieu naturel
des fleuves les montagnes l'histoire
exonérer les terroirs
mais tout ça dit beaucoup de ce que nous
sommes et où nous allons
alors où nous allons on s'est un peu
plus avec notre dame des landes
puisqu'on parlait de d'autorité de
l'état donc ça y est une décision après
50 ans après le début du projet une
décision a enfin sa ligne a enfin été
prise
oui et comme toujours quand une décision
évidemment il ya des des heureux et des
malheureux des contents et des
mécontents
on a entendu des mots très forts
d'ailleurs de la part d'eads et des jo
qui regrettent et qui condamne la
décision qui a été prise par par le
gouvernement et le président de la
république
ils ont certes un tournant du
quinquennat c'est l'aele l'autorité de
l'état a été bafouée c'est le le ceux
qui caillassent les voitures et les
policiers qui ont eu raison qui s'en
charge en tout cas c'est certain
renoncement c'est à dire que sous une
certaine pression renonçons avait
renoncé aux portiques à cause des
bonnets rouges en bretagne coup du truc
à un milliard de 20 milliards d'euros je
crois maintenant on renonce à l'aéroport
notre dame des landes
après des années de de dépenses d'études
après un vote suis pas qu'il y avait
l'air d'être relativement démocratique à
l'époque tout le monde arabe
démocratique mais on sort finalement le
vote
on s'en fout
donc voilà c'est curieux après qu'ils
aient des arguments pour et contre
l'aéroport c'est sûrement il ya sûrement
des bas mais sur le principe ce
renoncement de l'état est quand même un
peu gênant parce que ça va encourager on
a bien vu d'ailleurs tous les tous les
addicts qui sont là à vivre un peu comme
au moyen-age enfin c'est une sorte de
régression absolue fallu vivre dans des
grottes famille sans la nommer il
s'arroge des droits film incroyable il
en est installé dans avec des ours bruns
ont conçu la peau de bête non mais
écoutez mathieu et iris group paraît-il
c'est la france qui fait rêver c'est la
france qui va kim mastine sortir gagnant
de la grande bataille de la
mondialisation
là on voit bien d'autres l'âme des
landes c'est que le futur français est
absolument idéal quoi c'est à dire que
et et alors ça c'est un syndic mais
réellement et les tips à roche des
droits sur des terres qui ne leur
appartiennent pas coupe des routes
je viens ça fait quand même je croise
cinq ou six ans qu'une route nationale
est bloqué et je n'ai on est en france
fin on se croirait dans un an donne dans
un pays sans toit ni sont séparés sans
décision du ccri non mais ce que je sais
bien d'entraîner l'arrêt gens-là non
mais on a cédé face à face à ces gens
qu'ils cesseraient sais pas si c'est
parce que oui je veux qu'ils étaient
contre le report de votre prendre
franchement est ce que quelque chose
qu'ils avaient été décidés il ya
cinquante ans que le trafic aérien
n'était pas tout à fait le même
quand l'école est besoin n'était pas
tout à fait les mêmes avait encore sa
raison d'être aujourd'hui la personne
personne ne nie qu'il faut développer le
transport aérien qu'il faut désengorger
paris qui va falloir agréé augmenter les
capacités de l'aéroport de nantes au
détriment des gens qui habitent dans la
région etc
j'imagine que donc les analystes si son
corps envoie les à des à côtés de à côté
de l'aéroport à nantes pour sauver les
les grenouilles et les
et les gens qui l'habitent en piste je
j'ose espérer qu'il y aurait une
cohérence chez ces gens là donc donc vos
disques durs l'autorité de l'état a été
ben oui enfin sur wii oui je pense que
l'on peut dire ça qui n'est pas d'accord
avec ça votre question vous pensez que
moi je trouve que c'est très courageux
déjà d'avoir décidé quelque chose parce
que 50 ans en personne tout le monde se
repasse le dossier comme une patate
chaude et elle a enfin quelqu'un a pris
une décision mais de toute façon décidé
c'est faire un choix et faire un choix
c'est forcément un renoncement
quelle que soit la situation donc
là ils ont pris une décision et je pense
que c'est une décision extrêmement sage
alors vous allez dire ça je mets
peut-être pas courageuse dans ce lit ça
dans vos yeux
je pense que c'est une décision très
sage qui se basent quand même sur un
rapport avec des médiateurs après on a
toutes les contestations possibles sur
les noms des médiateurs maintenant le ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est ce qu'on va
faire de cette décision parce que là on
atterrit mais j'espère que tant le
gouvernement que les hadîths teillé bon
il ya une poignée de deux personnes
violentes dans les hadiths me sont pas
tous d'aider des gens violents et sont
des gens qui ont voulu faire valoir des
droits mais qui sont maintenant qu'ils
vont probablement soient évacués soit
les agriculteurs qui sont chez eux qui
n'ont pas été expulsées vont pouvoir
rester d'ailleurs
donc voilà le problème c'est de savoir
ce qu'ils vont faire de cette décision
et a de pouvoir sortir sur quelque chose
de positif et pas sur une guerre de
tranchées ce qu'il faut espérer que ce
que l'idée demandé aux analyses de bien
vouloir partir gentiment les applique
non mais ils appliquent la trêve
hivernale qui est qui et la loi en
matière de
pop art ami tu as eu la bastille en
matière d'habitation j'ai très bien
jusqu'à ce que pour ceux qui sont dans
des fermes ça vaut pas forcément pour
cent quand vous êtes quand vous avez une
décision d'expulsion quand vous avez pas
payer vos loyers le tribunal prononce
une décision d'expulsion vous explose
pas pendant là pendant la trêve
hivernale donc il ya un parallèle qui
est fait là dessus et je pense que là
aussi c'est assez raisonnable
d'appliquer d'appliquer la loi en ce
sens donc ça me choque pas non plus de
tomates est oui alors semble solidariser
sur tout ce qu'a dit jean charles à
propos des à dist en tout cas on peut
quand même reconnaître que effectivement
c'est un renoncement de l'état alors
l'état change avec 28 de ses
représentants à la suite en fait je sais
que c'est nuancé mais pour les
responsables politiques changent à la
tête de l'état ceci dit il faut quand
même rappeler qu emmanuel macron pendant
sa campagne
oui avez dit elle avait dit qu'il était
favorable à la construction de
l'aéroport donc il a changé d'avis
depuis sans qu'il y est d'ailleurs de
changement de circonstances qui puisse
justifier qu'ils puissent changer d'avis
de tout en restant cohérent dans sa
démarche tout la désignation de hulot
que ministre oui voilà ce que c'est
c'est plus une question politique une
question qui est lié à l'intérêt du
projet ils sont pas environnemental
économique et c'est donc il ya
clairement un renoncement dont on peut
s'interroger sur les causes
est ce que si on n'est pas la tête de
l'état et connaissant la cote de
popularité montant des manuels macron le
plus simple n'était pas d'un point de
vue politique aussi de de ne pas
s'embarrasser avec ce genre de dossier
dont on a vu pendant des années qu'il
était extrêmement brûlant qui créent des
complications et qui pouvait aussi
porter atteinte à l'autorité de l'état
et générer des problèmes extrêmement
important nicolas hulot était aux
responsabilités donc il l'a certainement
exercer une pression au moins implicite
urnes on jette à mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que ça aurait été compliqué
pour lui es10 access
une solution serait traitée aussi une
condition au maintien de nicolas hulot
aux responsabilités je m'interroge parce
qu'il n'ya pas vraiment en tout cas de
d'éléments qui me donne à croire que
emmanuel macron a pu changer de leur
apporte quand même y aller parce que ça
on fait toujours un rapport pour m et
après ce qu'on a décidé à vendre une
décision c'est toujours décider le
moindre mal peut-être aussi un peu
puisqu'il a aucune bonne décision dans
cette affaire
en tout état de cause ce qui va être
amusant c'est que effectivement on peut
comprendre que la décision était prise
en disant bon ça va calmer le jeu et
c'est enfin l'idée c'est quand même un
jour cette zone à définir enfin cette
date soit dégagée et je suis assez
perplexe
ça fait partie de l'asie et de on dégage
et bien voyons nous après la trêve
hivernale et même dans six mois et je
vous fiche mon billet que ça sera
toujours dans le même état il ne rompt
pas dégagé et on n'osera pas
envoyer la police qu'on dira oui mais
c'est dangereux machin l'histoire de
rémy fraises ils sont très violent ça ça
va être compliqué la route c'est pas
grave ça fait cinq ans qu'on fait le
tout on peut faire plus tôt pendant
encore cinq ans ils sont là ils font de
mal à personne il élève des vaches et
des cochons très bien laissons tomber
j'ai peur que de vivre dans des grottes
hinault mais je pense que dans six mois
la situation n'aura pas changé
stéphane c'est pas impossible
jean-charles que la situation ne change
pas mais je crois que les taaf à
restaurer son autorité enfin je sais pas
si le ceci en tout un peu fort mais
enfin l'état à exercer sa légitimité en
décidant il fallait décider peu importe
le sens au fond mais il fallait poser
une décision c'est vrai qu'en 50 ans
voilà et puis les commentaires qui ont
suivi manqué un peu de
un peu de décence se fasse ici si on en
est arrivé là c'est quand même là pour
le coup du fed de renoncements
successifs permanent de tergiversations
et surtout de volonté de ne pas
intervenir
j'entendais le patron des députés
républicains oui c'est jacob dire on ne
pouvait rien faire en 2008 2010 parce
qu'il n'y a pas encore de décision du
conseil d'état
oui il ya eu évidemment un des
feuilletons contentieux est extrêmement
long extrêmement diversifié tous les
actes de la prod de la procédure ont été
ont fait l'objet de recours devant la
juridiction administrative juge
judiciaire est aussi intervenue alors on
ne pouvait rien faire oui c'est bon
enfin c1 c'est un peu facile c'est vrai
que c'est à dist - pour lesquels j'ai
pas a priori de sympathie particulière
sont
des occupants sans titre enfin ça
s'appelle froidement des occupants sans
titre c'est à dire que j'arrive chez
vous je m'installe et je disais chez moi
et je les paye rien et je ne paye rien
et et je vous bip et je trouve ça génial
et c'est bon ce jeu je ne suis pas très
sensible ce soit pour le coup il aura
besoin d'attendre la décision du conseil
d'état pour agir ce nom puisque les
analystes non sens puisque quand je
quand j'arrive chez vous et je
m'installe je suis pas chez moi et donc
enfin les choses ont passé de ce point
de vue là assez simple mais ce qui est
vrai c'est que les recours n'ont été
comme on dit légalement purgé que de
manière très récente il ya dire que on
est arrivé aux décisions définitives
rendues par les juridictions à partir de
je ne sais plus de 1000 2013 vous
semblez tisme déclaration d'utilité
publique etc
si bien que pour la plupart des
territoires concernés le transfert
propriété au bénéfice de l'état n'a pas
pu se réaliser
ça a été le cas pour une certaine partie
du territoire dire que les analystes
sont aujourd'hui implantées sur des
propriétés privées
les fermiers et aussi sur des propriétés
publiques de l'état qui on est et qui
ont déjà été expropriés et donc on dit
aujourd'hui les fermiers vont pouvoir
récupérer leurs terres
les agriculteurs ont des plus férus ils
sont peut-être pas faire mieux encore
vont pouvoir récupérer leurs terres
contre leur versement d'indemnités d'ex
pro qui l'ont reçue s'appelle la
rétrocession et mais en tout cas voilà
il me semble qu'il fallait de toute
façon décidé ça a été fait et c'est vrai
je suis assez convaincu du fait que ce
projet était prise a été a été élaborée
sous
à l'époque pompidolienne vous savez on
voulait quelques traces fâcheuses en
matière d'urbanisme de cette ère
pompidolienne où on faisait les
autoroutes urbaines
on appelait les pénétrantes on faisait
des tours détours appareil à
beaugrenelle à montparnasse et c'est bon
et c'est vrai que il ya un aéroport à
nantes qu'il devienne un autre arrêt y
en a un autre à rennes y en a à brest un
peu plus loin qui est tout à fait
magnifique d'ailleurs bon voilà mais il
fallait décider juridique le fait
d'organiser un référendum
ça n'a aucune valeur en fait et bien ça
c'est pas un référendum selon
jean-charles non ça s'appelle une
consultation il ya une autre
non il ya une distinction juridique qui
fait qu'une consultation est un avis le
comité d'entreprise la cession immédiate
après la consultation s'y attendait il
me semble mais vous avez raison de
dissocier le juridique du politique
politiquement c'est compliqué de ne pas
tenir compte un avis et éventuellement
le faire plus vite alors pour le coup
faire immédiatement
ce qui n'a pas été fait et on était en
fin de quinquennat pression n'était en
fin de quinquennat il y avait il y avait
un il y avait un désaccord entre manuel
valls et ségolène royal et françois
hollande a décidé de pas décidé de
biffer très bien ça me choque parce que
demander l'avis des gens et ne pas en
tenir compte de lire ses cd goûter un
peu les gens de s'exprimer
on est toujours là à dire pourquoi est
ce que les gens s'abstiennent quand on
fait des votes
si quand yves sais quoi qui donnent leur
avis ils votent on n'en tient pas que
nous
mais après il va les débats sur la
géographie absolument d'accord c'est un
peu curieux de dire de limiter
géographiquement parce que c'est vrai
que ça concerne la nation mais c'était
quand même c'est quand même curieux
alors on peut parler des suites encore
de la sphère runtime
puisqu'ils lui cette pétition signée
notamment par catherine deneuve je suis
d' une contre-pétition la pétition
signée par catherine deneuve deux
modèles la liberté au forum de pouvoir
importuné des femmes elle s'en est
expliquée d'ailleurs dans une interview
à libération c'est assez intéressant
parce que c'est au fond une affaire qui
n'en finit pas est-ce que ça ça ne
dénote pas que c'est au fond un vieux
débat
une vieille revendication sur la
domination masculine qui est en train de
basculer et que tout ça tout ça montre
c'est pas quelque chose qui qui qui
existait et qui sort aujourd'hui quoi
avec avec une différence générationnelle
peut-être avec certaines femmes qui
demandent en effet le droit de pouvoir
être importuné et d'autres peut-être
plus jeunes qui sont justement dans le
mouvement de lutte contre cette
domination
bah écoutez moi je ne peux pas près de
faire ce que je suis c'est signé je suis
un peu étonné des des propos extrêmes
qui sont tenues ce soit par les
féministes ou par cette tribune descend
je me reconnais dans certains
certains produits dans les dents les uns
dans les autres dans certains propos
mais les excès des unes et des autres me
choque un peu moi par exemple je ne
souhaite pas reconnaître le droit de me
faire importuner ça c'est clair j'ai pas
être importuné c'est plutôt pénible donc
ça il n'y a pas de droit à être
importuné mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à dire que les hommes et les
femmes doivent pouvoir librement dans le
respect de l'autre exprimé son désir et
c'est là où il faut pouvoir arriver et
dans cette espèce d'équilibré et comme à
chaque fois quand on a des mouvements
mais ça crée des injustices et peut-être
non mais on est en plein dedans mais je
pense que quand il ya des maisons décès
d'un mouvement important c'est un moment
important et c'est bien enfin je trouve
que c'est bien que tout le monde puisse
s'exprimer et c'est tout ça sur la
liberté d'expression sur ça je trouve ça
très très bien et c'est vrai qu'il ya
des tas de femmes qu'on ait beaucoup de
choses à dire
mais ça vire très très difficiles sur
des sur dur des violences qu'elles ont
pu subir et c'est bien de le dire c'est
bien de l'exprimer après s'être tus
pendant tant d'années mais maintenant il
faut pas crucifié de manière généralisée
la totalité des hommes parce que cette
réponse signée par quatre oui enfin là
l'autre red bull est ce que ça veut dire
pas un peu à contretemps justement parce
que justement il se mouiller ce qui est
pas ce mouvement de fond qui en effet
est peut-être déséquilibre est en effet
peut-être produit un certain nombre
d'injustices
mais qui est un mouvement qui est que
rien n'arrêtera est ce que dira dire le
contraire aujourd'hui ça ne pas à lire
un peu à contretemps et forcément dire
qu'au contraire puisqu'elle disent pas
totalement le contraire elle n'affirme
que il faut arrêter les abus donc
condamne contre dans le viol condamnant
les toutes les les problèmes
d'harcèlement sexuel
ce qui est formidable dans cette dans
cette tribune est là dessus tout le
monde est d'accord c'est la dénonciation
de ce puritanisme vis-à-vis de l'art et
ça je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que service saas est
un véritable où il avait la morale de
l'affairé banon mais le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte aussi
que la morale elle rentre elle rentre un
peu partout là où elles devraient pas
être et il faut vraiment se battre sur
ce toit là ça fait partie mais c'est
bien il ya des yade il ya du mouvement
de fond de l'autre côté il ya des gens
qui expriment trouve que c'est très bien
il ya une ébullition que je trouve très
intéressante et puis il en sortira
quelque chose est ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'il en sorte quelque chose d'un peu
équilibrée et de liberté et d'égalité
dans l'expression du désir et dans le
respect de l'autre c'est vers là que
tout le monde je pense que tout le monde
sera d'accord là dessus c'est tout à
fait d'accord avec florence et mes
instructions sur les options de la
morale dans le
dans tous ces débats c'est que cette
tribune qu' on peut tout à fait
comprendre je respecte les gens qui ça
choque je comprends ce qu'ils la
soutiennent etc mais ce qui m'a
profondément déplu c'est que peu de gens
attaquent catherine deneuve peu de gens
attaquent les 100 personnes la seule
personne qui ait vraiment véritablement
attaqué dans cette tribune c'est
brigitte lahaie qui est traité plus bas
que terre comme c'est une ancienne
actrice porno alors elle elle n'a même
pas le droit de parler c'est à dire qui
et tout les films mais c'est le sous sol
mais c'est là c'est là le féminisme si
je puis dire se mord la queue parce que
vraiment je veux dire de l'attaqué cette
saison uniquement sur le fait que à l
appel de l est la paloise écrémé la
paroisse de donner son avis c'est une
actrice porno
tout le monde s'en est donné à coeur
joie parce que c'est une union par
pascal à celle de chaîne porno star
alors que personne ne lit vos manières
après une annonce sacrément attaque
relisez tout ce qui a été écrit c'était
vraiment il faut de intellectuellement
brigitte lahaie mais comme une reine
dans sa lettre d'enceinte et pas j on
peut on peut jouir en sont violés oui ce
n'est peut-être pas non plus la phrase
la plus intelligente
non mais ce débat là non c'est pas
sorties dont elle a dit ça dans un débat
avant il y avait après ce que ce propos
en expliquant que à son corps défendant
devant quelqu'un qui s'était révélé donc
cap à son corps défendant on pouvait le
corps pouvait jouer sans que le
l'esprit est bien évidemment la tête ne
jouissent du passé scotché dans le voilà
peut-être mieux de signer des pétitions
vous contre les écrits mais et de voir
quelles décisions c'est à dire qu'après
il ya eu une espèce de délire orale qui
de la part de certaines qui ont signé
cette cette tribune des sens qui fit que
4 et de l'axé là dessus
catherine deneuve a réagi en redonnant
une lettre ouverte qui a été publiée
quelques pas cautionner ce qui a pu
ensuite être dit postérieurement à ce
qui était normal mais elle ne se
catherine deneuve s'est excusé qu'auprès
de victimes de viol qui aurait mal pris
ou de victimes veut une ambition voilà
qu'ils se structuraient m'habiller la
tribune et c'était très bien mais elle
est là par rogner la pointe dès sa
signature est la compétition donc là
précisé à l'avant la position cette idée
est ce que c'est ça parce que c'est ce
que c'est pas quand même voir le petit
bout de la lorgnette de dire attention
on remet en cause la galanterie
masculine ça va c'est quand même plus
plus plus profond que ça ce mouvement
non il ya ce mélange fait un peu chocs
entre
que font beaucoup de d'intervenantes
dans ce débat qui c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ce serait pareil un
viol ou une main aux fesses dans le
métro les fesses dans le métro et c'est
sûrement très gênant mais c'est top
c'est pas quand même c'est un peu comme
la teneur de 2 tout ce qui se dit de
mélanger l'agression la tentative
d'agression le harcèlement et les
violences zones où il ya des délits et
des crimes et des incivilités et je
pense que chaque chose à quelques choses
très différentes et cet amalgame est
effectivement terrible non mais ce qui
est évident c'est de devoir après ce qui
est peu en être tirées notamment sur
parce qu'on parle que du consentement
des femmes
finalement continue être toujours dans
la même dans la même problématique qui
de dire que la femme finalement est par
essence victime est faible donc il faut
s'assurer de son consentement et quand
on voit dans les pays nordiques qui va
falloir cochet avant d'avoir toute
relation sexuelle sur son ipad
oui je suis d'accord c'est un vrai
délire ça aussi donc la balle et les
collègues america de 2 stéphane des
traumatismes pas seulement américains
mais aussi en france - d'histoire en
france mais il ya eu quelques quelques
difficultés avec les avec les doctorants
les rapports entre doctorants et et
directeur de thèse enfin doctorante il
est directeur de thèse puisque ce sont
des rapports en général pour l'instant
mais ça a évolué là encore où le
directeur de thèse est seul face à son
il ya un face à face la forêt ont fermé
et les oraux quand on fait passer les
oraux en général il ya ce que ceux et
celles qui prévient que son département
la même salle mais c'est la question se
pose pour le dernier le dernier canada a
aussi parce que ces publicités mais en
tout cas pour les raisons c'étaient les
entretiens individuels qu'on peut qu'on
a souvent à régler étudiants et
étudiantes dans nos on a la chance
d'avoir des bureaux ici à l'université
ce qui n'est pas le cas de feu te fasses
qui n'est pas le cas en principe dans
les autres établissements
moi c'est vrai que par réflexe ferment
plus tôt la porte
je vois heureusement qu'on n'est pas
obsédé je n'osais et oui oui il ya des
campagnes des campagnes sur les campus
on en a entendu parler un avec non c'est
non aussi si c'est pas un oui explicite
je n'y vais pas enfin qui vise pas
seulement les les enseignants mais qui
vise surtout aussi les étudiants en
entreprise et sur le fond sur le fond on
est dans la polémique
donc le fond et on a on a parfois un peu
du mal à discerner
on est dans une polémique donc avec des
arguments qui de part et d'autre sont
excessifs mais ça fait vivre le débat ça
fait vivre la liberté de s'exprimer je
trouve que la tribune des sens et ce que
dit 9 en assumant d'ailleurs une part de
ce qu'elle est c'est bien parce que bon
on peut en débattre etc
il n'y a pas une vérité absolue et
jean-charles le disait il faut sans
doute mettre un peu de un peu de nuance
m de la nuance ça n'est pas niée mais
c'est essayer de mettre un peu de
réalisme et puis sans cette nuance la
vie serait quand même très compliqué
donc essayer d'y voir clair
on y parviendra sans doute mais il ya un
progrès parce qu'enfin ces choses-là
sorte qu'il ya des choses qui sont qui
sont plus admissibles
mais voilà la polémique va sans doute
s'apaiser elle renaîtra peut-être mais
on pourra peut-être ensuite débattre de
manière un peu plus est ce que vous
pensez qu'on a fait un mouvement de fond
quand même après cette affaire weinstein
hacker qui renverse quand même les cette
domination masculine qui était qui était
celle de l'histoire de
l'humanité jusqu'à présent non oui alors
ce qu'on en est là ce que c'est aussi en
tant que ça ou pas ce qui n'est pas
nouveau c'est effectivement ce principe
même une domination masculine mais en
revanche effectivement ce qui est
absolument nouveau c'est le fait que un
grand débat national et mondial
en tout cas occidentales plutôt que joue
sur ces questions qu'est-ce que c'est
forcément ça joue sur ces questions et
de ce point de vue là c'est extrêmement
intéressant je trouve que le débat est
absolument compliqué on a l'impression
que l'on voudrait donner un petit peu
raison et tort à tout le monde et c'est
vrai que ça interroge alors moi ce qui
me gêne un petit peu dans le débat se
sont effectivement c'est ce qui a été
dit c'est les excès de part et d'autre
et cette idée que finalement on dit d'un
côté on peut faire si et de l'autre on
ne peut pas faire ça alors que je crois
que la question est plutôt de savoir
jusqu'où on peut aller
en fait quelque part fasse un rapport
homme femme
donc d'un côté on peut balancer comprend
que consentent eh oui mes mains mais
bien sûr il ya cette idée du
consentement mais au delà du
consentement ya pas uniquement des
questions pénales il ya aussi des
questions de bienséance dorures de
cordialité de quotidiens des choses dont
on sait que voilà qui mord allemandes
sont pas justes jusqu'où on peut aller
lorsque un homme désire une femme et
réciproquement aussi comment se
comporter alors pour les uns il faut
unir regarder ni touché pour les autres
une main sur la cuisse et tenter un
baiser on peut le faire
donc voyez ça pose des questions plutôt
degrés c'est à dire de quelle manière se
comporter dans quel contexte avec qui
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avant et du
coup je pense que le vrai débat il est
plus sûr des éléments de contexte par
rapport à une situation donnée que sur
des principes abstraits qui consiste à
dire on peut faire si on ne peut pas
faire seul nom n'est pas encore là
je pense pas qu'on en soit encore dans
ce qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ce qu'on
peut bien faire mais c'est sa création
quand même qu'on a à faire un mouvement
très important ce qui s'avéra qui
s'arrête à roanne on dit s'arrêtera pas
et on reviendra pas en arrière et
qu'evra pendant trois ans dans les
cultures et musiques dites inclusive qui
écriture plutôt ségrégationniste mais
enfin ça se sait voilà il ya de
multiples indices avec ont en effet
probablement des erreurs probablement
des probablement des injustices mais
dans toute révolution entre guillemets
il ya toujours sans vie souvenez-vous de
2,2 des méthodes éducatives dénoncer
quand najat vallaud belkacem est niet au
ministère est magnifique théorie du
genre en réalité n'existe pas mais il ya
quelque chose se produit alors on va
parler de versailles et de recours qui a
été fait par le barreau de versailles
contre une mesure qui avait été décidée
par l'ancien ministre 16 la justice
suédoise a été le dernier 8e justice de
de françois hollande et qui consiste à
mettre des cages de verre pour les gens
qui sont
au procès il faut qu'ils passent en
sciences et en correctionnelle je
suppose a alors mentionné entassés en
correctionnelle pour tout un chacun
phoque tous ceux qui se font arrêter qui
passent en comparution immédiate par
exemple pour des choses dont pas
forcément très très grave
ils comparaissent dans des cages de
verre ou des cages de métal parce que ce
sont les deux qui peuvent être installés
et là enfin on n'est pas dans la nuance
parce que ces cages de verre existait
déjà mais n'existait que dans certaines
cours d'assises est lié et on faisait
comparaître détenu dans ses cages dès
lors qu'il y avait un très grand profile
un problème de dangerosité d'évasion etc
sauf que là en 2016 la décision est de
généraliser ces cages de verre et ses
cages de métal et il n'avait rien été
fait entre eux la décision de 2016
jusqu'à fin août 2017 ou les présidents
de tribunaux et la ministre de la
justice ont fait installer enfin je
pense que toute façon le gouvernement a
hérité de ce dossier et que les bons de
commande étaient déjà passés avec les
avec les entreprises qui est et les
traduire mais l'important c'est ce que
je vois c'est ce que nous demandons donc
on les travaux ont été faits pendant
l'été 2010 est et pendant des week-ends
de l'automne passé sans aucune
concertation avec les barreaux et donc
nanterre à nanterre découvert le premier
qui a découvert ça c'était de faire
d'enquêté recours fin 2010 est donc il
ya des recours devant les tribunaux
administratifs alors il ya de versailles
a fait des recours là cette semaine
devant le tribunal administratif qui a
été plaidée lundi un autre devant
tribunal de grande instance qui a été
plaidée hier on attend les décisions le
celui devant tribunal administratif
c'était qu'ils ont attrait le ministre
de la justice et le président du
tribunal pour qu'il sort soit fait ordre
de retirer des cages de verre et il ya
une expertise qui était demandé devant
tribunal de grande instance parce que
ces cages de verre portent atteinte
d'abord à la présomption d'innocence
parce que dès lors qu'on est enfermé
dans une cage mais totalement enfermé un
puisqu'il n'y a aucune aucun moyen de
deuil et pas de portes y a rien donc on
est déjà dans un autre ressort la
présence militaire jusque ça mais on est
déjà coupable
être enfermé dans cette 15e journée car
on est déjà plus voilà donc il ya une
atteinte à la présomption d'innocence il
ya une atteinte aussi à la liberté de
communiquer avec son avocat puisqu'on ne
communique difficilement puisque on doit
se parler au travers de cache pas les
avocats dans la cage de verre juge aussi
m je sais qu'il ya une atteinte des
trompes une attente aussi avec lui il ya
une attente à l'oralité des débats
puisque on peut il parle aux juges au
travers d'un micro mais alors il ya des
tas de problèmes évidemment technique
journaux mais sachez que certains ont
défait le procès oui ou le silence des
agneaux si on nous avait aussi savait
c'est vrai que ça donne pour protéger
sans retrouver l'agent pas du tout donc
non non c'est pas l'objet d'une annonce
est pas de protéger ces passerelles
décision alors là d'ici la première
décision qui a été prise c'est que la
ministre a gelé les travaux au mois de
décembre face à donc elle a arrêté les
travaux déjà que ça ça permet d'éviter
d'en démonter ça c'est fin c'est bien
donc
les travaux ont été arrêtés au mois de
décembre sur décision de la ministre et
à l'attendre voir ce que donnait il ya
des tas de deux présidents de chambre
correctionnelle qui demande à ce que les
gens soient sortis des cages de verre et
ils comparaissent libres avec une
escorte derrière eux ils comparaissent
dans les noms ça ça a été fait à la cour
d'assises du val d'oise ça a été fait
dans différents tribunaux correctionnels
de mais il n'y a jamais que je devais
vendre c'est pour les surveiller donc
oui non mais c'est non mais le problème
c'est qu'il n'y avait jamais de problème
enfin je veux dire si c'est pour lutter
ya jamais de difficultés en france
étaient unis d'évasion dans les couloirs
de l'instruction plus que des
actionnaires sur nouveautés gênante
évident qu'elle a fait le titre avait
pris en otage
non mais c'est fermé c'est une ville a
aussi ses on dépense un argent fou pour
faire quelques idées pour alors ah ben
je ne sais pas et bien sûr à part lui et
valartis urvoas
oui donc ah bah non parce que les mêmes
les magistrats sont voilà donc ces cinq
cette décision parce qu'on la découvre
en gros maintenant mais là c'est à dire
qu'on la découvre au moment où les
travaux sont dans ce sens on va suivre
évidemment suite des décisions
peut-être un mot alors on est en 2018 et
alors il ya deux anniversaire cette
année ça sera les 50 ans de 1968 mai 68
et les 50 ans de mai saborder c'est à
dire l'arrivée de de gaulle au pouvoir
la vème république
but de vue dit si évident maintenant
qu'est ce qui vous paraît plus fêter les
60 ans de 58 tous les 50 ans de 2,68
ces nouvelles questions c'est une très
bonne question et je vous remercie de
l'avoir sous la menace possible 68
eh bien voyez je pense qu'on vit sous
les soul empire des deux hommes me sens
triste et je ne nous voyais pas malice
dans mon propos qui on avait donné
raison
retraitement bayrou n'aurait sur ben pas
daigné pour faire mais c'est important
on parle beaucoup de 68 on parle pas de
58 mais regardez comme un sous l'empiré
du centre regardez ce dont nous nous
venons de parler et comment nous en
avons parlé c'est à dire nous avons
parlé à chaque fois notre presque d'une
forme d'autorité qu'il fallait que
l'état exerce dans sa légitimité et de
l'autre d'une forme aussi de démocratie
de liberté d'expression de liberté
d'être les deux
liberté de moeurs etc donc il ya
peut-être un peu des deux finalement
vous pensez pas moi je pense aussi mais
c'est une très forte une
instrumentalisation toujours à laquelle
on échappe que très rarement de mai 68
avec la chienlit avec tout fout le camp
etc
mais il ya eu aussi d'autres choses un
peu plus un peu plus fondamentale qui se
sont fait la différence c'est que 58 et
chose très française 68 est une phase
plus internationale
le vieux mairie celle là dessus je le
rejoins parfaitement stéphane c'est à
dire que je crois pas qu'il faut
complètement opposé ces deux moments ne
serait ce que parce que finalement les
institutions de la vème république ont
permis tout simplement ce mouvement
libéralisation donc
on aurait pu avoir un système
constitutionnel et politique qui ne
permet pas ce genre de mouvement et puis
aussi parce que tout simplement il ne
faut pas oublier que finalement quelque
part il ya aussi joints 68 et jouant 68
c'est le général de gaulle qui face à la
chienlit donc évoqué stéphane prononce
la dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
pour demander aux français s'ils
souhaitent ou pas le reconduire aux
responsabilités et les français ont
donné une majorité écrasante sacramental
au gaullisme donc on comprend bien trop
grave
oui si vous allez par là on pourrait
dire qu'il ya aussi 69 et la référendum
et oui mais du coup ça reste des
questions des banques aidées mais
combien je pense que finalement ça veut
dire que c'était plus un débat qui a
porté sur des enjeux de société et sur
des enjeux moraux et non pas finalement
contre le politique en lui même on a
donc je pense que ce sont deux choses de
choses différentes saveurs mais 58 ça a
permis d'éviter la guerre civile et
d'asseoir nos institutions et mai 68
c'est c'est l'ouverture du boulevard du
libéralisme qui fait qu'on est est-ce
qu'on est aujourd'hui et donc c'est mais
curieusement vous avez curieusement
c'est bon c'est plutôt le libéral
libertaire ccl libéral qui a gagné
avec cette défense du et de cette
défense de c'est j'ai le droit je fais
ce que je veux dès lors on en parle
peut-être par la génération j'ai le
droit de projets mais ça c'est assez
intéressante donc je pense que mai 68
fait ce que enfin on est ce qu'on est
parce que mai 68 est passée par là sur
l'ouverture du libéralisme est et le
plus d'individualisme code collectif
finalement mois sur les deux dates sont
absolument passionnante
ce qui m'intéresse le plus c'est
effectivement 68 ce qui en a découlé ce
qu'il en a pas découler l'héritage 68 où
on en est maintenant
cinquante ans après effectivement c'est
un vaste désert à l'est j'aimerais
beaucoup de choses à dire a regretté que
c'est la farce et la génération de 68
ans première fois voilà c'est en gros 68
et et et je revient alors aux
institutions et est très bizarrement
parce que jusqu'à présent jusqu'à
l'élection d'une macro tous les gens qui
essaient essayé d'espérer quelque chose
qui partent de cette coupure droite
gauche disait mais faut un changement
des institutions
il faudrait revenir vers plus de
parlementarisme etc
les élections de 2017 l'e-sata ce
minéral ont prouvé au fond le contraire
que donc les institutions de la vème
république sont assez plus souple
peut-être qu'on ne le pensait elle songe
plus à un professeur que j'avais que
j'aimais beaucoup qui disent elles sont
plastique s'en passe des institutions de
la vème son plastique simple question
souple elle s'arrêterait il ya eu 23 ou
24 révision oui encore la constitution
mais mais a logiquement sorti oui elles
montrent leur robustesse c'est vrai que
la 6ème république aujourd'hui on en
parle un peu moins sortir la tête mais
ça montre oui la très forte date
habilités de cet appareil
constitutionnel qu'on pensait plutôt
rigide en cinq ans tuée et au moins
oui car baptiste le tuez moi je moi je
trouve que en tant que citoyen puisqu'en
tant constitutionnalise qu'on a un
système constitutionnel absolument
formidable moi je suis absolument
hostile et au passage ben oui d'abord
parce que vous faites au cours de droit
qui s'appuient là-dessus
jamais je n'aurais pas pensé
ceci dit c'est pas tout à fait vrai
parce que la 6ème république qu'on nous
vend c'est une république on a connu
pendant des décennies sous la troisième
à quatrième et que finalement on veut
revenir un système d'hypertrophie du
parlement par rapport à l'exécutif et je
crois qu'en france ça ne fonctionne pas
et que ça et que je suis d'accord pour
ce système mais uniquement si on le met
en place en suisse
merci merci de cette course je remercie
beaucoup jean baptiste pierre que
florence mercadé c'était fade manceau et
jean-charles la jolie et à très vite
pour un nouveau bof
[Musique]